what's up everyone this is Anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Peter Johnson leads junk
capitals investments in the FinTech
insure tech and crypto and blockchain
sectors in this conversation we
discussed the stages and types of
companies that jump capital is investing
in how they work with companies the
value that jump trading brings why he is
so bullish on stable coins and Peter's
deep personal conviction and where the
space is going as well as how committed
jump as an institution is to it guys
bang bang I have Peter here with me all
the way from Chicago we've got a ton of
talk about so thanks so much for coming
to do this great to be here thanks for
having me absolutely all right hold on
we're starting already with the you got
talking to the microphone yes I've been
waiting to embarrass people on the
podcast about talking into the
microphone so I just got my first victim
I'm sorry what did you do before jump ah
yeah so I started I was a management
consultant I did strategy and operations
worked for banks brokerages and asset
managers do that for quite a few years
then saw what investment bankers were
doing so financial structuring looked
pretty interesting so went to Morgan
Stanley and did financial structuring
and M&A work again for banks brokerages
and asset managers and did that for a
little while and then met the the
founders of jump capital just as they
were starting the firm and and took the
jump over what year did you jump over to
jump and in 2013 okay and what was the
biggest takeaway from all of the
structuring and working with Bank
success that's gonna be fascinating to
kind of see under the hood of those
deals yeah it's really interesting work
for me total finance wonk really
interesting doing that type of work also
saw it just how slow financial
institutions are like innovation does
not happen at big financial institutions
so I said that was the biggest takeaway
and one of the biggest reasons that I
left those types of positions got it
when you joined jump 2013 any idea of
crypto were they talking about crypto
Bitcoin anything or was it more in the
FinTech and financial services world
yeah so when I joined
jump capital which is the venture
capital arm of jump trading I was just
as the firm was starting in 2013
beginning of 2013 met Mike McMahan in
such chitnis where the two guys who are
in the process of starting the firm at
that time and I joined them was this
really unique opportunity to help build
a venture capital firm come in lead to
FinTech investment for them and at the
time I'd heard of Bitcoin wasn't really
a focus was certainly wasn't a focus for
the firm back at the beginning of 2013
but I started paying close attention to
it really close attention to it shortly
after I started it was I forget exactly
one in 2013 it was actually the what
happened in Cyprus where you know the
government was going to seize bank
deposits the price of Bitcoin jumped
that's what no pun intended right yeah
but that's what first got me like really
reading about Bitcoin and like okay like
are people really buying this magical
Internet money instead of they're you
know keeping money in the bank because
if so like either that's crazy or
there's maybe something there yeah and
what did you guys do to figure that out
like so I think there's a lot of people
who went through that mental exercise
and during that time period and then
they didn't do anything you guys went to
go try to figure it out and some manner
was that more of like passive research
by like googling around you could talk
to people like what do you guys do to
figure that out yeah so it was reading
everything possible which there was not
a ton you know back in 2013 to read
about talking to everyone that knew
anything about the space starting to go
too early crypto conferences which were
fascinating and interesting and then
bringing the right people onto the team
and I think it was 2014 or so actually
hired the general counsel from Erik
Voorhees from first startup or one of
his first ones coin appalled if you
remember that but hired him for a summer
to help me get smarter on crypto really
yeah that's amazing and so at what point
do you guys say okay we thought that
this might be a thing let's go do some
research too this is the thing that we
want to participate yeah so it was
started looking into it from a venture
investing perspective in in 2013 and
then it was not until I think late 2014
we made our first equity investment in
the crypto company so it was a Singh
again amount of time that we spent just
getting smarter about the space looking
at opportunities and also working with
the trading team who in you know around
2014 is when they you know started to
get active in the market mainly down at
our research lab down to jump labs but
started to get into the market and that
really helped push our thinking as well
yeah it was a long fairly long kind of
incubation you know evaluation period
before we before we end in so before we
go any farther I want to make sure
people understand the difference between
jump trading and jump capital jump
trading is a trishal kind of Wall Street
and air quotes type firm where they
essentially trade all different types of
assets in a very kind of quantitative
trading methodology but maybe just
describe you know had the firm get
started and what does that look like
today and then we can differentiate that
between jump trading and jump capital
right so jump trading is a one of the
leading quantitative trading firms in
the world that can we say the leading I
say one of them but they are a I would
say massively successful proprietary
trading firm based in Chicago they've
been around 20 years a highly
quantitative highly research-based trade
most every asset class in pretty much
everywhere around the world and just as
an amazing firm what they've done over
the last 20 years
jump capital is the venture capital
affiliate of jump trading we operate
generally independently from the trading
organization we're structured as a
fairly typical venture capital fund okay
except the capital that we invest comes
exclusively from the owners and
employees of jump trading so we also you
know because of that worked very closely
with the trading firm you know kind of
went appropriate for making investments
so I lead our FinTech in capital markets
and crypto investments so I am very
often working very closely with the
trading side of the firm FinTech in
crypto is just kind of one sleeve of
what we do at jump capital okay also
invest in iTune data infrastructure b2b
SAS and media companies a lot of those
the vast majority of those have nothing
to do with the trading off operation but
just are your more typical venture
investments guys so just good investment
opportunities and really the thread
there I think across the media b2b SAS
and the IT infrastructure it sounds like
as more infrastructure platforms etc
it's not what encrypted would be call
like an application or media publisher
etc yeah absolutely it's it's a lot of
the kind of infrastructure for those
types of companies is typically what
we're investing in it's a lot of
data-driven companies that's definitely
a theme and kind of the way that jump
capital differentiates itself is when
it's a thesis driven firm so we go very
deep in areas and look to invest you
know develop a thesis of how we think
that space is going to develop and
invest invest companies in that space
and then we're also very operationally
focused so the team was started the firm
was started by folks that were operators
they've built and run companies from
startups all the way up to public
companies we built an operating team so
we have folks that help our portfolio
companies with recruiting especially
around data science and engineering with
with M&A with finance with corporate
development you know connecting with
potential partners and acquires
with with sales and customer success so
we're very very active and involved
investor and that's kind of how we
differentiate ourselves as well as in
crypto and FinTech we differentiate
ourselves by we're also connected with
one of the smartest trading firms in the
world yeah and so when you look over at
the FinTech capital market it's crypto
stuff from venture perspective how much
of the investments you guys make there
are companies that could be partners or
help the trading firm versus these are
just good financial investments that we
find interesting in those specific
verticals yeah it's a good split between
those there's a lot of fantastic
investments that we do that have nothing
to do with the trading world we're
investors in personal capital which is
the best online investment manager and
one finances which is great for the
do-it-yourself investor and allows you
to borrow against your portfolio you
know a lot of companies like that where
investors and companies like trading
view which kind of span like they are in
capital markets but it's you know not
necessarily strategic with the trading
firm and then we're investors in crypto
exchanges and futures exchanges which
are very clearly strategic to the
trading firm so it's a fairly wide
inspector guy so trading
a good example right we're talking a
little bit before we start recording for
people in the crypto world trading view
is one of if not the go to like chart
type platform right so you can go in you
can chart a bunch of stuff and as I like
to say just draw squiggly lines
everywhere into every one where you
think the price is going but from the
trading of you see crypto is like
probably maybe one of the smallest
markets right or a very small market
because they're in equities and all of
these other spaces and so it's funny to
me how like the crypto world thinks
trading view so important but trading
view has you know I'm not I said if they
don't think crypto is important right
but but probably they're larger markets
if you just look at it from a size
perspective or dominating this little
small crypto market you know so depends
on which side of the market you're
sitting on there yeah it's funny you
talk to crypto folks about trading view
and they assume it's a crypto company
crypto is definitely not the largest
market on trading view much larger in
equities and FX and in other markets
yeah it's interesting about crypto is
certainly a big big part of what they do
and an important part of what they do
yeah and really leads to this idea of
you know you're looking at FinTech
capital markets in crypto depending on
how you slice those three those could be
three very very separate things or those
could be identical right in terms of
what company look at how do you think
about it as you guys are sitting there
saying okay we're gonna cope with thisis
are they vertical specific or do you
more come up with kind of thesis and and
future you know evolutions of these
industries and you don't worries that a
FinTech is that crypto and try to kind
of place it in a bucket yeah right now
they're still fairly bifurcated like the
crypto world and the FinTech world are
are different generally you're starting
to see more overlap companies that are
doing both crypto and FinTech things
think like you know like a Robin Hood
for example and then you're also
starting to see crypto companies which
are building FinTech companies except
they're just building it on different
rails
I like your investors in block five
great company you look at what they're
doing they're taking deposits and making
loans that sounds like a like a fin type
company mm-hmm and so how do you find
these companies you guys come up with a
thesis what
kind of okay we think exchanges are
gonna be important what's that process
look like for you guys to go find
investments yeah so we find investments
you know kind of three different ways
one is just very thesis driven that's I
would say the primary way and that is
like we think for example you know
Wealth Management it's gonna become
digital or kind of hybrid digital so
let's go find out the best company in
the space for us that was personal
capital or we think I kind of Fiat on
ramps and off ramps for crypto around
the world are gonna be incredibly
important somewhat obvious but ok let's
go find the best companies in each
country that align with that thesis we
just invested in bit so for example in
Mexico which aligns with that so that
kind of very thesis this is how we think
the world is going to develop let's go
find the best companies that align with
that view is certainly I would call that
the primary way we also you know find
companies through relationships we have
with entrepreneurs and with other
investors because we don't have a
monopoly on ideas there's tons of things
that we come across that we never would
have thought to have a thesis on but we
see what somebody's doing and wow that
that's really amazing and then we also
have some systemic sourcing ways out
just to make sure we're seeing
everything got it and what stage are you
looking for yeah so we're mainly
investing in series a companies so 3 to
10 million dollar initial investments is
what's typical for us we also have a
what we call a growth equity strategy
which is investing in profitable or
close to profitable companies and then
we'll occasionally make seed investment
so earlier stage smaller investments I
would say in crypto that's one of the
places that will look you know maybe
earlier be more flexible just because
the industry is so early and there's
companies that you know the trading side
can be strategic to sometimes yeah in in
crypto specifically it sound like you
guys are looking at financial service
related infrastructure right so things
like block Phi exchanges bit so excetera
same thing there in terms of the split
between how many of them can help the
trading side or the trading side can be
helpful versus the ones that are you
know kind of non-correlated
yeah so in that space like a lot of them
do you have like the trading firm can
add significant value sometimes very
very significant value too
companies that we're investing in but
some of them just are fantastic
companies billing building things that
are really interesting but they have
nothing to do with the trading operation
or maybe they just don't have an
opportunity with the trading operation
at this time so there's there's a pretty
good split there as well yeah got it
and then let's go through kind of some
of the theses that you guys have or a
place that you guys have been investing
so bit so obviously as one they have a
lot of fiat on and off ramp never around
the world maybe talk through a little
bit as like what that deesis looks like
and why you guys are so bullish there
yeah so our view kind of I would say
kind of my core beliefs are one Bitcoin
is digital gold that's gonna be adopted
in portfolios - is that stable coins are
going to become money transfer or
transfer rails and FX rails that enable
money to move around the world that
three emerging markets will increasingly
adopt crypto assets and that for that
the infrastructure is going to be
developed to enable those first three
things to happen so if you believe those
things like how does how do people get
access to Bitcoin if it's going to be
digital gold and how does you know if
stable coins are going to be the rails
that money moves around the world like
you need at the endpoints you need to go
back into fiat currencies at some point
at least right now so if you believe
those things the gateways in each
country that allow that that fiat -
crypto conversion are absolutely
necessary and key to those things
happening so a bit so we're extremely
excited about one because you look at
remittances if you think remittances are
going to be a big use case we do I do us
to Mexico remittances are a massive
market how Biggie's think that is you
probably actually know I do know I don't
remember the number offhand
are we talking just ballpark we're
talking a you know a billion dollars a
month are we talking tens of billions
Ateneo basis I don't know yet right yeah
it's a very large number yeah and the
amount of remittances that are going
through bit so has been increasing
exponentially bit so just announced I
think over the last week or so two and a
half percent of remittances to Mexico
are now going through bits oh really
yeah and those are all across crypto
rails yes
Wow and I mean it's fascinating to me
because there's a lot of things that go
into that right that two and a half
percent numbers impressive just in
general but that means that one people
who are sending the money got to figure
this out - they gotta understand about
your proposition three they got a sign
up right and be able to use it and then
four is the person on the receiving end
is got to figure out how to use it as
well yeah so that's it is a lot of steps
but most those steps actually aren't
happening okay because it's being
abstracted away from the end-user how
because the end-user doesn't know that
they're getting crypto what's happening
and I think is going to drastically
increase is that for example remittance
companies are saying hey how do I get
money to Mexico I you know I take
dollars I go to the correspondent
banking system they get converted to two
pesos they come out pay so this on the
other side I'm paying X amount of fees
for that or I could take dollars go into
Bitcoin or XR PE or some cryptocurrency
send the two bit so converted to PI
pesos there and then I know what my fees
are total cost on that rail it's just a
different rail and remittance companies
are increasingly just looking at it as
another rail and so so bit so is frankly
it's not interfacing with the center of
the receiver they're acting more as the
infrastructure before the remittance or
a lot of that remittance flows yep it's
completely abstract away from the users
yeah
and so then really it's not the sender
and receiver have to make this decision
it's the remittance companies which to
some degree is easier I guess because
it's only you know a couple of decision
makers that a company have to make the
decision once and then all their volume
can you know come over and go through
bit so but to is it's much harder
decision because it's not like the one
user who signs up and says $10 now
you're talking about an entire
corporation understand the value of
profit and switching over so there's
kind of pros and cons between the
difference of being the infrastructure
provider versus then use your provider
yeah absolutely yeah it's it's super
interesting because okay so you guys got
that where the companies encrypt aside
bid go it's one fairly recently that
we're incredibly excited about and
what's kind of the thought process there
yeah so private key security and custody
for crypto is and will continue to be
like one of the biggest issues I know
you wanna argue that come on
all right just incredibly important like
securing private keys it's a bearer
asset like there's nothing more
important than securing those bit go is
the provider the wallet provider the
custody provider for a vast swath of the
crypto industry and they have put
themselves at one third they're just a
trusted provider there's a trusted name
like people trust bit go and and at the
end of the day I'd if your custodian
you're selling trust and they've been
doing this for a very long time and a
lot of people trust them they've also
built this incredible network of you
have a lot of the industry is costing
their assets with you you're a great
position to provide settlement solutions
to provide lending solutions to hold
everyone's asset and allow them to
transact with each other without
actually moving that outside of your
custody just puts you in a really good
place to provide the back-end
infrastructure for how the industry is
going to work in the future
it is very similar to traditional
custodians like a state street or it's
not it's not a you know kind of name
that a lot of people know but they're on
the back end for a lot of what's
happening in the the financial services
industry yeah
might as well just keep going to your
portfolio I've never done this before
Murr we're gonna we're gonna keep going
until tea relative companies what what
is the one company in the portfolio that
you think people be most surprised you
guys have invested in o most and just
some people at home know most of your
investments are public but there are a
couple that aren't so we can only talk
about the ones that are public obviously
yeah so yeah so what would be the the
one that is known to folks but would
still be surprising in terms of it'd be
kind of a off the beaten path or
difference in strategy yeah Spring Labs
okay is a little bit different which is
so spring labs is building a
decentralized credit bureau a
decentralized credit bureau yeah for
like lending services for lenders okay
it explains more so how they are
enabling so the founders of Spring Labs
came from avant which is a massive
online lender based in Chicago and what
they saw is that credit bureaus are
effectively creating they're taking in
data from lenders and other sources and
then they're capturing rents by selling
that data back to the lenders that they
are taking from the lenders good
business model people will buy it great
business model good business model to be
disrupted so what they're what they're
doing is they they're saying hey
how can we use you know basically
blockchain technology to enabled lenders
to share information securely with each
other and get compensated for that
well while disintermediating the credit
bureaus or working alongside the credit
bureaus yeah kind of depending on who
you ask so what is the benefit to the
individuals in a transaction right
whether you're a borrower and lender
using that decentralized credit bureau
versus a traditional one gonna mainly be
for the the for the lenders themselves
guys if an lender and it's more like
accuracy of information or yep the
accuracy of information cost of
information you know things like loan
stacking where people are applying for a
bunch of loans at the same time with
online lenders like if there is a better
way for lenders to simply share
information with each other about to is
loans with them and who's applying for
loans you can help solve that problem
yeah this is it goes into this trend I
haven't talked too much about but I sort
of think more about so a lot of the
businesses today that are quote online
they start out as businesses that were
not online and then they had to catch up
this internet thing happened and like
how do I get my credit bureau which used
to be one the analog world now I got to
get it online right and so they
basically took what they had and they
modernized it a little bit but really
did try to fit what they had to the
internet when I see R like decentralized
credit bureau or other people doing you
know these kind of digitally native
businesses what they do is they start
building a high level it's a credit
bureau but the way that they get there
is much more digitally native much more
built for the internet much more for our
global world but like it changes and so
decentralization is true in some of
instances sometimes it's not
decentralized but that to me feels like
a pretty big shift in the way that
people think about building businesses
in certain verticals is because one is
built and then brought online another's
built for the internet or for this
global digital world and if you do the
latter it seems like that's a much more
scalable valuable type approach then hey
let me build it how everyone else has
always built it and just put it online
yeah absolutely and then that kind of
spans our investments in in FinTech and
in crypto like a lot of our traditional
FinTech investments are just like how
can we build something that is native
natively digital
which can compete you know better with
these historical businesses that are
trying to transform their business to
compete in a digital world
got it what are some of the other themes
that maybe you guys have an investment
yet that you're either looking for
companies are you're excited about I
mean the the the lending and borrowing
market we haven't explicitly invested in
although Bidco is certainly in that
market but that is a market that is you
know absolutely you know taking off it's
maturing you know really excited about
where that is so we're certainly looking
at you know solutions there and have you
looked at so right now I think most of
the lending and borrowing is happening
in what I'll call like true crypto
assets right says Bitcoin etherium
digital dollars whatever but have you
seen people doing stuff with traditional
assets that are tokenized or digitized
or is that still really really early and
more kind of theoretical than people are
actually executing on it I think it's
mainly theoretical that's what I've seen
yeah yeah like the traditional the like
digitizing or tokenizing assets I think
that the most interesting part of that
by far is currencies the effectively
staple coins like how do you bring
stable coins our fiat currencies into an
open network kind of that is freely
tradable I think that that is the first
kind of major shift that we'll see and
that will happen you know well before
you know we really see it's like let's
tokenize equities or real estate or
you know gold or other things like that
mm-hmm and what's the fascination with
the stable coin so yeah like you're very
very bullish
yeah more bullish than most one there's
data right this suggests that things
like tether accept are being used pretty
widely but what else kind of drives that
bullishness for you yes the one is just
looking at the data looking at Heather
for example there's been shown there is
huge demand for US denominated
settlement and trading accounts for
folks that don't have access to the
banking system or want to trade on in
places they don't have access to the US
banking system and more generally if you
look around the world there is strong
interest in a lot of places in having
USD denominated savings like Venezuela
you know they've they've it seems like
they've embraced dollarization so how
does that happen
digitally stable coins is my view the
best way that that happens and so let us
take Venezuela or even like you other
more kind of nefarious actor slash
sanctioned countries like diarrhea North
Korea's etc part up the knock against
the USD C's G USD true USD s all of
those types of stable coins that are
originated here in the United States is
that they're still heavily regularly
regulated right now but that kind of air
quotes for those listening at home
because they can be stopped
assets can be frozen they could be
seized etc I think Heather for example
is much more kind of unregulated kind of
outside of some of those controls etc do
we get a world where there's
consolidation around one or two of these
stable coins or do we see kind of a
plethora of the variations and it's kind
of a buffet like pick what you want
depending on what you need my
inclination is that there would be
there'll be various table coins for
various degrees of regulation so like
yeah like tether is like an unregulated
open network and I don't think that's
going away at least in the near term I
think tethers market capital increase
over the next year more people will be
using it I think that there's gonna be a
very large market for regulated open
networks which are coins like USD see
like why do you start interrupt but
regulated open network the regulated
part makes sense when you talk about
open networks is it open because
theoretically they wouldn't come use it
is it open because like how do you come
exactly yeah and I think that that gets
to the core of why I'm so excited about
stable coins okay is because it is it's
an open network is that anyone if you
have a crypto wallet you can receive
dollars in USD C or other stable coins
the banking system the traditional
banking system is a closed network you
agree to you that you need to onboard
with a bank to get into that network or
if you're a business and you want to
have say you know real time settlement
you can go to silver gate and you can
onboard into the silver gain exchange
network but that's a closed network you
need to onboard into
with stable coins do you have a u.s.
dollar open network that anyone with a
crypto wallet can join or for you know
Mexican peso it's an open network if you
are a US company that wants to own pay
so someday there will be a peso stable
coin and you simply need to receive a
peso stable coin in your crypto wallet
to own pesos so that's where I believe
the world is going and why I'm so
excited what stable yeah it gets at the
heart of you know one of the things that
I don't agree with that it's kind of a
public narrative or debate is digital
currencies versus fiat currencies like
to me is a foregone conclusion every
currency will be digital right now the
question comes down to what does that
look like right so kind of regulated not
regulate it open closed but also what is
the monetary policy that supports that
digital currency and that's where the
competition to me exists is people now
will have accessibility to all of these
different currencies now there's
competition at the monetary policy level
like if you're in Venezuela if you can
access dollars the one the euro you know
name your other favorite currency and
they're all readily available on an
exchange that crypto exchange where all
you use a internet connection what do
you use is it brand awareness like hey
the US dollars the US dollar and I trust
the Full Faith and Credit of the United
States is it monetary policy and so now
you start to actually learn more about
it like what drives us decisions around
adoption I don't know like I don't think
there's a clear answer but that becomes
a very interesting world because right
now usually what country do you live in
okay what's the native currency or the
reserve currency of that country that's
what you use right because it's just an
accessibility thing but if you take if
you break down those walls and you give
choice and have more of a free market
competition is that good or bad
I don't know what do you think I think
it's a good thing okay why it gives
people more choice and it allows people
in places with you know currencies and
banking systems that are not working
another option yeah not all currencies
are good not all currencies are good
yeah so I think that that's a good thing
to give people options if you asked you
know is it is it good for people in
Venezuela in Argentina and places like
that to have other options other than
there
local currency I think most people would
agree that that's a good thing is it
good for the governments I think that's
an open question yeah cool cuz it not
all governments are the same right so
like you could argue I guess one side
the argument would be digitised
currencies from major superpowers would
bail out the failure of the Venezuelan
government to the Venezuelan people
right so you've hyper-inflated away your
currency basically your people are
suffering if they don't have access to
something else it's critical good for
you as the government because now all of
a sudden you don't have to go come up
with the solution like they can just get
access to a different currency and they
kind of stop the bleeding vice-versa
I don't think there's a lot of
governments I want to give up that
control maybe it's like because the the
escape hatch or the bringing competition
into a market makes actors behave better
and are you going to have massive
inflation in the country if people have
other options yeah so maybe that will
happen less like I don't know I'm just
speculating at these things but I think
overall like it's a good thing and that
it will be like it will be because you
for the first time have open networks at
any because it's always been closed
Network can you live in a country your
money is kind of the closed Network the
money of that country in ten years that
won't be the case you're gonna have a
lot of options and that that's that's
going to be very different and very new
one of the arguments I haven't heard
that many people talk about that I would
love for somebody to argue I'm not even
gonna say whether I agree with it or not
cuz I would have to think about it more
is the digitization of the dollar would
actually further enhance the dollars
dominance right so this idea that if you
digitize the dollar more people have
access to it because it is the global
reserve currency today more people would
adopt it and therefore you would
actually build a deeper moat around that
global reserve currency because
accessibility is one of the biggest
barriers to that happening I think that
there's a credible argument there I
don't know the probability of that
happening is yeah I feel like that is
the logical argument I'm not enough of
an expert in that space to argue for or
against it but the case that you just
made seems very logical well and I guess
it begs the question then do you think
that well there's dollars one
whatever central banks do this or
private companies like us DC is
technically a digital dollar G USD is a
digital dollar right tether is a digital
dollar all done by private companies
versus the government's themselves
killing is that a sustainable model or
do we need the central bank's to do it I
think it will largely be done by private
companies like what we're seeing right
now okay why do you think that because
it's central bank digital currencies as
they're proposed in most places are
issued on private blockchains or
databases even it's basically the
government is keeping the records so
like how are records kept is kind of
what we're talking about here like in
the current system for individuals kind
of balances right now the current system
is banks keep the records in crypto
we're all keeping the records in central
bank digital currencies as they're
generally proposed the government is
keeping the records in most places the
government doesn't want to or really
have the capability to keep the to keep
the records some places like China I
think would be the exception to that
generally added like I don't think the
US isn't going to start keeping the
records of all kind of US balances for a
whole variety of reasons so I think that
will be done by kind of commercial banks
and technology companies as we're seeing
right now how do you think kind of
surveillance and the nefarious
activities of governments play into this
right so like one of the arguments alex
client Gladstein from the human rights
foundation is chief strategy officer
there it's not a fantastic job outlining
I don't know if you could say it's a
probable situation as much as it's a
potential situation where governments
realize hey this technology is great
because now I keep track of everything
and if I want to know what my citizens
are doing I should digitize my Curtin
currency pull cash out of the market now
these just digital one digital dollar or
whatever it is and I have full
surveillance over all their financial
activities scary right very scary but is
that enough of a pull to get people to
do it like to get the government's to do
it how do you think about that I don't
know I mean I hope not like that I think
that that is the the fear when you talk
about central bank digital currencies is
just kind of what you outlined is is the
is the nightmare scenario or the
scenario that people worry about I
certainly hope we don't go in that
direction and I don't think we would in
in most countries but yeah but that's as
the concern yeah some of them for sure
and then I think about corporations
interacting with these stable clients
right so if you look at like a bit so
who's doing more like remittance type
stuff that's one component but you SDC
tether or whatever it is business's
gonna move money you know around the
world as well do you see adoption
happening there you have any insight
into like how they're thinking about
these stable cause of digital currencies
yeah my hope is and my belief is that
long term they will or at least this
will be used on the back end for what
they're doing it's it's like it's a
better way to move money like you move
24/7 money 24/7 it's open on the
weekends I mean I think that we're at
the point now where it's like pretty
hard to debate it that it's not better
right like it's cheaper it's faster it's
24/7 365 it's available in every country
you didn't have a hard time compelling
the same that like business our business
is looking at using stable coins right
now for moving money around now like
general corporations aren't that's not
even on the radar at this point you know
it probably will be at some point or the
vendors that they use will be using this
as rails on the back end which is
probably more likely yeah all right what
other what are the themes other than
kind of stable coin stuff are you you
interested in you said lending and
borrowing I mean like market
infrastructure like how does this market
evolve to look like more traditional
markets in ways that it should so that's
something that we you know look at a lot
because we are very close to the
traditional markets so things like you
know different types of companies in the
crypto market focusing on their core
competencies and kind of getting
separated out into like should there be
shooting an exchange be a brokerage and
a custodian and does this all really
belong together or should there be
companies that are really good exchanges
and really good brokerages and really
good custodians that's something that we
think is certainly like the market is
maturing and it's going in that
direction so we look to certainly invest
behind that trend so in traditional
markets there's definitely folks who
come from traditional world who look at
crypto and they're like I can't believe
that the exchange and the custody
provider are the same right or some
other variation of these different
components being vertically integrated
he's crypto different like is this time
different or do you think that whether
it's regulation or just market forces
force these two separate become
different service providers for whatever
reason I think that generally it makes
sense that they are different companies
that are providing these services if you
look at because the core competencies
that you need for each of them are
different to be a really good broker do
you need to be really good at acquiring
and servicing customers for being an
exchange it's really about bringing
parties together you know having that
network effective liquidity is is the
kind of the key to having a second
successful exchange for custody its
security its securing you know folks at
assets is especially in crypto is the
most important thing so why would the
same company have all those different
core competencies which are very
different so I think it's very natural
that they get separated into you know
best-in-class for each of those I think
you see that even you know Brian
Armstrong a Clem bass recently said that
you know the the coin base like they're
they're separating the brokerage from
from the exchange which which make to
end the custody piece like they're
breaking it down just like you would
expect from a traditional market so i
think i think that the crypto market is
learning from traditional markets on you
know kind of what works in traditional
markets but they're also learning what
didn't work and like their gun going to
like kind of take over places in the
traditional markets that they can
improve upon for exact like why are
markets not open 24/7 like that that's
absurd like the crypto market is open
24/7 like why are markets not accessible
to everyone the crypto market is
accessible to everyone so i think that
that's where we're going is we're going
into a future where you're gonna take
the best things from the traditional
markets that crypto markets is going to
learn from and they're also going to
improve on the things that aren't ideal
in the traditional markets so this is
one of my favorite topics which is every
once in a while I'll see a tweet dunk
which essentially if somebody quote
retweets some announcement and says
congratulations
you learned finance and it's usually
somebody from Wall Street or the
traditional markets realizing that the
crypto world was unsophisticated in some
aspect right and the announcement is
basically getting too
kind of a comparable you know position
as the traditional market so could be
something around regulation around
custody you know whatever it is and the
reason why I like talking about it is
because I think from the finance
perspective a lot of folks are like hey
idiots like we been to this a long time
like we know we're doing right which oh
okay that's a position to take I think
the other argument though on the crypto
side is wait a minute
just because you or do something the way
you do it doesn't mean that there's not
a better way to do it right and those
two forces collide a lot I think in
crypto and I think what you're saying if
I'm understanding correctly and correct
me if I'm wrong is if you start out
saying well maybe there's a different
way to do it sometimes you're gonna end
up saying well the way they do it is the
best way so we're gonna do it that way
but sometimes you end up saying wait a
minute there's another thing to do and
like it's an improvement on that old
world is that exactly right yeah yeah
and that's a great thing about crypto
it's that it's kind of building a new
financial system from the ground up and
sometimes you land well the existing
financial system kind of got it right
and sometimes you land the financial
system got it way wrong and we're gonna
build something better yeah how do you
know if you're like from the investor
seat right when you're talking with a
founder and working with them how do you
know when
oh the existing model works versus we
should go innovate or create something
different is that like a pretty
black-and-white let's go left let's go
right or is it more of you just kind of
keep doing what's best for your business
then you end up somewhere I think it's
more of the latter and I really like
companies that have people that come
from both like you they people that know
the financials traditional financial
space and they know how it works and
then you've kind of more crypto native
folks that I think they can bring both
those mindsets into maybe you know what
works and what doesn't and what we can
improve upon because it's not always
clear yeah it's um it's interesting to
me how we're seeing the disruption and
innovation and hasn't seen that very
much right I think the tech world is
used to it at this point they they kind
of know how this stuff you know okay
here's the market cycles here's how you
going to these large industries there's
very well understood business models you
know hey we're gonna execute the
platform strategy we're execute this you
know b2b strategy whatever Wall Street
pretty much has done the same thing for
a long time and you know if you think
about crypto starting at
most important component which is the
base unit of account and having
innovation there around like I'll say a
Bitcoin now I get need a stable coins
etc like can we rebuild the financial
system can there be a complete
replacement or is this we coexist you
know the the crypto world and a legacy
financial world I think it's definitely
a coexist like I I'm gonna push you on
this why oh I just have a very hard time
seeing a future where you know the
crypto world displaces the traditional
financial world in you know the develop
market ok I just don't think that will
happen I think that there is
opportunities in other markets that
maybe don't have a as a developed of a
financial system ok so you're gonna
bifurcate let's say take the globe
bifurcate developed undeveloped or
developing world's i think is an
appropriate way to say it the developed
nations much harder to see the financial
system as it exists today completely
going away and then developing we're all
easier to see that happening raise that
exam so far yeah okay I don't disagree
on the developing world side right in
terms of if you don't have a lot to
start with and something new comes along
it's pretty easy to see people wanting
to switch right now
somebody's got to build bad it's gonna
work all that kind of stuff but but
that's pretty self-explanatory in the
developed world let's say you were right
the legacy world can't go away if you
were the disrupter what are the one or
two things that you would have to see
happen to change your mind well like
what would be hey X happened oh you know
what actually I think they could get
disrupted and I and I'll bail you out a
little bit with this question I don't
know if I have an answer but it's an
interesting way to think about okay we
both agree that like legacy world's
pretty big they're pretty powerful it
works you know I was joke USDollar
working United States pretty well right
but what would have to happen to say you
know what actually this crypto thing
could displace or just completely
disrupt the legacy world I think you
need to find the the little places the
edges where where crypto is is better
okay like so you would go more outside
in you got to start gaining traction
somewhere where crypt is better yeah
yeah like if I find those places where
where
where it's a little bit better and is
this kind of what you're thinking about
with like bits oh and the remittance
type stuff exactly yep yeah yeah like
find that find the place where it's just
like kay where we need to get you know
dollars into pesos and get those in
Mexico what's the best way for us to do
that it happens to be using crypto rails
so we're gonna start using crypto rails
we're gonna we're gonna start
experimenting with it and then you know
maybe it's better ten percent of the
time so we're gonna be using that ten
percent of the time and then you know
crypto markets are getting more liquid
spreads are getting tighter it gets more
than ten percent next thing you know all
the remains sister Mexico are going
through crypto rails because it's just a
fundamentally better rail yeah it sounds
like the Trojan horse type you know
model right we're hey do you want to get
paid and you know you're gonna send
money back to a country that your family
lives in right so traditional remittance
I'm your employer and I say would you
like to get paid in the currency that
you send right and you say you know what
I'll take 10% of my salary
well at some point you say okay give me
more give me more you more and do you
say you know what I'm gonna send the
money I send back but then the money
that I keep here in the u.s. I'm
actually gonna keep in that currency as
well and now I want to spend it I want
and it almost like eats into your wallet
share to some degree or your portfolio
share I haven't thought enough about it
to know like how realistic that is but
it's an interesting way to you start on
the fringe or like the more like toy you
know type thing and then eventually it
becomes more serious and like oh [ __ ]
like you know 80% of my wealth is in
this thing yeah like how do you get that
little little edge and you talk about
like how do you get folks of Zera I
think it's the same for these use case
it's like how do you get people focused
off your ops here how do you get you
know part of their innovation budget
like using this in some way and trying
it because it's a lot harder to get it
going from 0 to 1 it's much harder than
going from you know one to fifty and a
hundred agree I definitely grew with
that all right you're bullish I'm
bullish what's your biggest fears in the
market like what do you what do you wake
up and when you wake up you're like if X
Y or Z happened I would like go do
something else so that won't happen
I'm as a bold statement I'm hyper hyper
bullish on Krypton okay so what would
like the would I worry about and I did
want to ask you this as well what would
I worry about like what's most damaging
the crypto space is if regulators decide
they want to really clamp down on crack
though and just kill innovation like
outlaw you know holding crypto in you
know the major developed markets that
matter this it obviously does not shut
down Bitcoin and crypto at the network
level at the protocol level like you
think you can't shut that down that's
why bitcoin is bitcoin but if you you
know shut it down like you cannot hold
these things you can't work on them like
that it that is just very very damaging
to the industry so by far that's my
biggest worry ok so if you ask me same
question I have to that's one of them
for sure and again I think I think
you're saying the same thing of it's not
because you shut down Bitcoin it's
because you basically kill the adoption
and the innovation and it's kind of its
kind like drugs right like look drug
still prevail in the United States and
sense if they're there people use it
whatever but if it was legal there's way
more people who would use them then
probably not yep people are straight
going to use Bitcoin and the network you
can't shut down but if it's if you if
you outlaw it then it's only criminals
using it and like that that's a
nightmare scenario that yeah so my other
one is uh I call it the self-inflicted
wound
right there's we rush something happens
and there's a bug introduced into the
code or something where like it has
nothing to with the external forces
there's nothing to do with how Bitcoin
is designed has nothing to do with kind
of a Black Swan event or regulation or a
stuff it's just simply we all trust that
code is being contributed and it's
getting introduced and it goes to a very
kind of serious vetting process that's
pretty methodical for a reason etc but
if at some point there was a bug that
was introduced that wouldn't be good so
I think about those two things which
ones external ones internal but at the
end of the day they kinda end up at the
same place right where it ends up not it
either ends up being not as valuable or
it's a massive massive I wouldn't even
say it's a speed bump is probably a stop
sign at that point right in terms of
regulation yeah if you talk about what
could effectively you know kill Bitcoin
like those are I think that's probably
the biggest two things yeah what about
Facebook and Libra and Calibra and all
that what
your thoughts sir so love it because
it's getting everybody talking about
Krypto
I think that somebody needs to onboard
the world to crypto which is like one of
the very much aligned with our thesis
and search calibra the wallet kind of
that their goal is to onboard the world
indeed crypto so I think that that's
fantastic I love that will you know
Libre eventually look like you know as
it is proposed it might is it more
compelling if you just do individual
stapling currencies my personal view is
that first is a basket but overall I
think it's highly positive I mean I'll
admit I lobbied hard for them to just do
a Bitcoin just do Bitcoin yeah I mean
because it's look yes I understand
they're saying there's too much price
volatility can't be used as means a
payment but you know whatever but it's
also the most decentralized is also the
most adopted is the most liquid and in
hindsight it probably gets you from a
lot of the kind of regulatory backlash
that they're getting or at least from
the the legislators etc the question is
like that short-term pain is there a
long-term gain right versus Bitcoin or
stable coins that already exists
probably wouldn't have that short-term
pain because the wreckage whatever but
is that long-term sustainable we don't
know right we may never find out but to
me it's it's hard to come out and say I
hate where to create new currency when
your Facebook right and like even though
there's other corporations or whatever
like I I can almost this is one test I
would love to do I'd love to go ask
every single Congress person who created
Libre they would all say Facebook right
yep and then if you said name five other
corporations that are Libre Association
my guess is that I don't think that a
single Congress person could do it five
of the 21 probably be tough yeah cuz you
know I I don't think I could cuz you
know the names that most people know
like if we went and asked people in
crypto they know the names of the
corporations have left the card networks
yeah right like you know I can tell you
that strife was in there I can tell you
that you know you know ABCD whatever
but the people who are left actually
like I would struggle to name five of
them and so is that good bad you know
you can debate that all day long but I
do think that that's part of this as
well as like you haven't seen Amazon you
haven't seen you know Google you haven't
seen like to me Tesla is a no-brainer
for them to image to come out with their
own digital token and it's more of like
a credit and their energy grid right and
so all of a sudden you got a power wall
you get your Tesla charging it all so
like why can't your Tesla car pay for
the energy that it is using at the
electric vehicle you know education yeah
yeah I'm sure at some point somebody
there's thought about that right and so
we start thinking about that stuff it's
a it's pretty crazy that you know 11
years ago know this existed and now here
we are talking about we've come a long
way amazingly all right what one area
around the world are you most excited
about
other than the major developing markets
oh I think that the the emerging markets
are are the most interesting place for
crypto by far so why is it because
there's less competition because there's
more real use cases for it okay because
if you look at the like the use cases in
development markets for crypto broadly
like digital gold a Bitcoin is the most
compelling use case in my view if you
start to go to places that don't have
you know stable currencies and good
banking systems then it's it's beyond
digital gold its actual you know
payments and using for commerce which at
which I think gets a lot more
interesting so you know Latin America
Africa some parts of Asia I think that
that's where the most interesting things
in crypto are more likely to happen yeah
and do you think that's kind of what
like Jack Dorsey at at Twitter and
square sees cz at by Nance you think
that's kind of why they're spending so
much time in these areas yeah absolutely
yeah Square and Twitter ever merch I
love this conversation because I gotta
just throw wild I'd never thought of
that one hey so here's my here's my
pitch I don't have it opinion whether
it's gonna happen or not but if you said
to me it happened
and I had to come up with a thesis as to
why Twitter has connected individuals
around communication and all of a sudden
if you overlay it with a payment network
so take paying businesses write using
square and then also paying individuals
through the cash app and I overlay the
communication layer in the payment layer
I don't know what that looks like but it
something new and could be super
valuable and like who's the one guy
who's super bullish on both of those
things and owns companies that do both
Jack Dorsey makes a lot of sense right
and so because this idea of connectivity
to me is its new right so we know how it
works when it comes to communication and
individuals so like let's say you and I
30 years ago live in the world two
different cities the way we communicate
is basically faxing telephone maybe we
were really really early to like an
email type service or letters right and
that's how we communicated the second
that we get internet connections we get
services where we can communicate
sharing um information and feedback
loops you know all the things we know
that's great about the Internet
well like that happened to words and
text and communication when that happens
to money like that to me feels like an
even bigger deal than communication
right but is that really what's
happening in crypto or are we simply
saying oh no the people who are already
connected via communication now we're
trying to put money in there as well
like are we onboarding new people to
money or are we just simply trying to
improve the people already have access I
think we're moving from from closed
networks to open networks and I think
that that is what happened with with
communications with a lot of things that
they used to be closed networks and then
explain that though what why do you
think we're moving to open networks what
it comes to money because before the
internet like most things were closed
networks most things were not accessible
to everyone like that that's kind of the
major kind of innovation hard yeah
innovation of the Internet is that it
opened information up to everyone now
that's what I think we're we're hard
seeing with money is that money has been
closed networks and now with crypto
money becomes open networks that anyone
can access money anyone can access
different types of money so death I
think kind of it's that same type of
disruption which is really interesting
so I don't disagree with that then leads
to is do we eventually get to a point
where there's a separation of state and
money and not in like the let me caveat
this I'm trying to be better about not
putting people in bad positions not in
like the anarchist way right like hey
we've got to take down the dollar - for
that to happen but in the sense of you
as a user have a government currency you
have a non government backed currency
then you've got these like digital
hybrids right where it's a u.s. DC so
it's not technically the one that the
government issued was digitization of a
government currency let's say there were
three options when you have those
options you as these you're gonna choose
right are the other two sustainable it
will the regulators will the
government's allow non-government
currencies or like you said earlier kind
of that that really really bad case they
come in they say absolutely not we're
gonna regulate this out of existence
yeah my hope in my vision on how it
plays out is that it is different fiat
currencies and crypto currencies coexist
it gives people options they can use
different things for different use cases
to transaction around the world you know
to hold Bitcoin as kind of the asset
that I think it will be as part of a
portfolio and a store of wealth to
transact and you know they're different
different currencies for different you
know countries that they're in or you
know parties that they're interacting
with that's what I think and hope it's
going so I go even further
what's the uncomfortable idea in the
room true separation of state and money
governments no longer in control money
if you said in the mid-60s one day those
paper notes in your pocket will not be
backed by gold you would have blasphemy
right like no way is that ever gonna
happen 19 what's 71 or whatever it was
right happens to me the world will look
a lot different and so I don't
necessarily think it's going to happen
what I think is that it's a higher
probability than people assigned to it
rest is almost like world
we're mispricing the probability and
what I don't know is if that's good or
bad right so let's say that if I went
out on the street and asked 20 people
the consensus would be there's less than
a 5% probability of separation of money
and thus
and actually if you could somehow
measure this and come up with an
equation that probabilities actually
fifteen percent right
still only fifteen percent not very high
but differs between five and fifteen
pretty material that's a very
interesting really we're edging more
towards this like way maybe the world is
not expecting something right
and I don't think a lot of you were
talking about that no I mean does the
world go in that direction my
inclination is no but at the same time I
agree we as people generally underpriced
the probability of drastic changes
happening so I think that's fair yeah is
there anything else that you've been
thinking about in crypto that you
haven't heard anyone talking about like
what do you think is important whether
it's for 2020 or beyond that you're like
man I wish more people were talking
about X I kind of think yes I think no
come on you got to have something
I mean people are talking about what I
think is the other thing we haven't
talked about or directly hit on that I
think is kind of most interesting is
when when and how does this become like
a real global macro play that we see
like somebody come out and makes that
like they're gonna be the next Soros and
they're gonna make their name in crypto
okay before I dig into that what would
what is kind of the the milestone that
would put somebody there is it they take
a lot of fiat and convert it and then
they're very public about it is it they
make some directional bet like how do
you ask about I think it's like a big
global macro hedge fund that that
publicly you know says we're all we're
all right we're all in in a meaningful
way yeah we believe this is how the
world is going and we are going to put a
lot of risk on the table in terms of how
when Ray Dalio writes his letter that he
definitely wrote about kind of how the
world is broken yep
or the system is broken but he instead
of ending it with buy gold hands it with
buy Bitcoin like I think that somebody
like Ray like making that announcement
could could be a seminal moment for for
the industry okay
I don't disagree at all that that would
be a seminal moment for the industry my
question is historically do the
innovators who became the man Rick as
every innovator always becomes the man
look back in history
Bill Gates was disrupting and now he is
the man everyone's going to try to
disrupt the Microsoft same thing happens
in finance so the radios of the world
Steve Cohen's always guys there were no
names that built into who they are today
can you get the innovators who became
the man to do that or do you need new
innovators to disrupt the kind of old
guard I'm not sure what it looked like
what do you mean so to me I don't think
that you're gonna get those big global
macro folks no matter how much time you
spend with them on it I think that it's
classic innovators dilemma right your
entire life you've made money and been
very very good but if you look at money
as the the score
you've been highly highly successful
you've won almost every game we've ever
played with one specific strategy with
one specific view of the world one
specific understanding of the system to
get somebody to flip that on its head
around separation of money and state
decentralization you know digitization a
developing world adopt technology before
developed world you know all these kind
of different mechanisms I don't think
you can get those guys to do it right I
think it's actually the opposite I think
you need young people who those ideas
are not as radical to them but they
almost don't know better right they're
too naive to know the world works you
know
option one yeah that it's not gonna be
you know Dalia and Cohen that you know
dude it's good it's gonna be folks that
become the next value in Cohen yes
because of what they're doing yeah so
like what that does though is that puts
you in a position where that next Soros
that next Dalia whatever probably is
already here right but we just don't
know who had it like like who becomes
them and whose recognizes them one of
the anecdotes that I have that blew my
mind and frankly made me feel old was I
asked my brother who's 23 years old I
said hey you ever set a bank wire and he
said oh what's that and I said you know
fair right I said how you said money to
your friends he said two ways I said
okay he said venmo and uber they for
those that are only listening yeah yeah
Peters had a pretty missable reaction
right so yeah then no makes sense uber
what he was hinting at was when him and
his friends take an uber together they
split the ride and so he's not actually
sending money to his friend what they're
doing is they're essentially combining
capital to pay for something but in his
head his buddy ordered the uber and his
buddy then same thing as requesting
money on venmo his buddy is requesting
that they share the ride so he just hits
accept whether he's accepting on venmo
natural mechanism is monies going to you
or we get in the car together and you
request to help pay for the ride and I
just hit accept the user experience
saying for me I accept that's
interesting and so I started think about
that I was like
like a like either I'm an idiot I'm old
or both cuz I never thought of it that
way
but it just really started to make me
think like if you grew up with a phone
in your hand right and all of these
digital technologies FinTech companies
except like that's all you've ever known
you do think about money differently you
do think about these mechanisms and the
way that you you know kind of conduct
transactions and commerce etc very very
differently then even me who's I'm 31
years old not somebody would've told me
like I don't understand technology or
finta Advan like yeah maybe not but here
we are yeah and and and it's gonna be
really interesting like years from now
and you have people that are coming of
age that grew up in a world where you
know Bitcoin wasn't a new thing like
like that's and like do they do they
have crypto walls before they have bank
accounts and like what does that mean
like it'd be really interesting I want
to know how many kids under the age of
18 have venmo but no bank account
actually I don't know if they could sign
up for a bin MOU account but I will tell
you you know what they do have how many
kids have the Starbucks app and their
parents put money onto their app so they
can buy things versus have been count
way more have the Starbucks app I bet
how many kids use either their parents
credentials for uber or have their own
uber account and their parents deposit
money into their ruber account way more
than a bank count like again is that
good right vertical specific accounts
where your parent is still the same
thing rather than me send you money your
bank account and you know when I was a
kid my mom put 20 bucks in my bank
account I was ecstatic go swipe my card
and you know I was rich but if today
they're doing it on your Starbucks or on
your uber right is that the same thing
yeah it's digital dollars that's not
incorrectly held with a bank like it's
subscribe you to think about all right
for people who want to pitch jump where
can they go I the Chicago VC on Twitter
reach out to me there all right are our
DMS open teams are open all right
why do you DM s-- open you like it so
founders can find me all right that's
fair or info edge
Capcom okay um Twitter I think is the
best tool in the world yeah love Twitter
all right somebody tweeted yesterday
they said yo Jack if you ever wanted to
charge us all $1 a month now it's time
to do it
whenever with glue this spoors Paul
takes potential war like everything
going on on Twitter they're like dude
right now would be a really good time to
turn that that monetization on but it's
all there
right and then are there specific types
of companies you're looking for right
now Series A ish yes Series A ish
typical for jump capital you know the
three to ten million dollars series a
investments companies with meaningful
revenue that is the core of what we do
if there are companies that are you know
in the the trading investing space love
those types of companies if jump trading
can be a partner or liquidity provider
customer you know strategic partner in
some way that's even better
absolutely love to hear about kind of
anything there all right
any last parting words before we get
into the rapid-fire
I think you want people to know other
than you got a pretty cool Twitter
handle the Chicago v6 how you see it
what happens if you moved you change it
or you keep it or are you never moving
never moving never leaving cryptic all
right you guys heard hear he's never
gonna leave Chicago what's the most
important company in crypto other than
jump jump is pretty important I think
the easy answer is Finance because just
the way that they're innovating and like
blitzscaling a crypto native country
company my view is actually bit-bit
go-biz go ok watch o because we talked
about earlier like they are the
infrastructure provider for such a big
part of the industry private key
security is so incredibly important and
I think that there's significant network
effects of being kind of the largest
independent custodian in the space kind
of the back office an infrastructure and
services and tools that you can build
off the back of that I think is
incredibly important now I would say if
I would add one more the sleeper is Lmax
digital which has quietly built what is
probably the largest krippfist bought
exchange in the world
and I feel like a lot of people don't
even know their name all right explained
I could go back digital because they'll
so it's LM ax yeah yeah yeah L Mex
digital I I mean they they just put
their their volumes up publicly so for a
long time they didn't publicly disclose
volumes they're now up you can see them
and they're providing infrastructure
where people could tap into or spot
exchange yeah but it's spot where any
consumer can go in and use it or it's
mostly like trading firms and mainly
trading firms yeah so they're based in
the UK it's a lot of us folks haven't
heard of them yeah and they are focused
on trading firms so a lot of people
haven't heard of them but that's where I
you know a huge amount of actual spot
crypto trading is now happening is on
Lmax digital did you guys invest we're
partners with them got it
and then you guys invested it bit go
right yes people get all upset when I
don't say who invested in what now I was
accused of talking about great companies
and not saying which was I invested it
or not I said it's like jeopardy you got
to figure it out
all right what um what is the one
regulation or law that you would change
if you could Oh a bit license probably
it's just such a hassle first for New
York yeah it's pretty crazy it still
exists yeah like my favorite fact about
the bitlicense
is the gentleman who like led that whole
thing then left started a firm to
consult people to then navigate it like
so I got one one rule in politics which
is I wish that there was a rule that
said if you're a politician and you get
elected into a seed representative
whatever we go back and we look at who
put you there right so whatever industry
was your biggest donor you cannot
legislate over that while you're in
office so you're a congressman
healthcare is your biggest donor you get
put into office you can't actually vote
or legislate over the healthcare
industry because you're bias right I
actually think that now ha when I heard
this bitlicense thing it's like same
thing like hey you can't be a regulator
create a law that is so ownerís and hard
for people and they turn around of it
okay now pay me and I hope you navigate
this yeah I don't know if you read like
Matt Levine
talks about that's the best thing to do
is regulator it's actually you create
really tough laws because then you can
gives you a lot of work when you go to
the other side and you consult around it
so I haven't heard him say that but I
get his even everyday I don't read it
every day but when I read it like he's
fantastic so good he uh I wish that he
did like a stand-up comedy right like in
terms of he didn't have to be that funny
because it's kind of you know dry humor
type stuff with with finance but like if
he just stood there and talked about
like what he writes about and she's like
a one-hour special put on Netflix I'd
watch I watch it alright what uh what's
the most controversial thought you have
in crypto that everyone when they hear
it will disagree I don't know if
anything is that controversial I would
say that I am much more bullish about
the future of stable coins than most
people I talk to you it's not really
cool I'm not really comfortable oh oh
most important book you've ever read
principles by Ray Dalio why that one
yeah so I mentioned a lot yeah
so Ray I think is one of the most
probably most awful investor in the
world what I love about principles is
it's about looking down your career in
your life like it's a machine and really
understanding how that machine works and
being the designer of the Machine
instead of just kind of being part of
the machine I think that that's just a
brilliant way to think about your life
in your career and everything so this
idea of being able to step out of your
body and take a more kind of transparent
honest view of where you are excetera is
very similar to a concept that a jackal
will Nick the Navy SEAL commander has
where he basically I tell the story you
know one time they were doing an
exercise and he realizes like no one's
leading and all of a sudden he just took
a deep breath and he took a step back a
physical step back looked around figured
out what's happening and then just
started ordering people what to do and
he said like that's one of the things
that he does in a lot of his executive
coaching and corporate coaching is like
hey you can't just be in the weeds every
day like sometimes you got to take that
step back I think that's kind of what
ray talks about in other words but
similar concept of just like designing
right now being aware of what's going on
in a broader picture which is uh it's
pretty powerful
absolutely you have a second most
important book I don't go most and
second most important I would say most
interesting book I recently read ok with
devil take behind most would have
Voltaire said yeah devil take the
hindmost I don't know if that is the
subtitle is a history of financial
speculation ooh
ok devil take hind most devil take the
hindmost ok check that yeah so it goes
through history kind of every you've got
a period of spec financial speculation
so tulips yep railroads so see bubble
and kind of how each of these you know
bubbles or periods of financial
speculation played out and it is one is
just absolutely fascinating entertaining
read and two you can very clearly see
some of the ways that things are similar
and not to crypto which has kind of gone
through many periods of financial
speculation Joe put it back up there Joe
is on top of it he's got the computer
and he's pulling it up on Amazon that
there it is my my goal this year is to
get people to start coming up to me and
asking where's Joe because Joe is always
sitting in the corner or record the
podcast he's firing away all right
aliens what uh what do you think believe
or non-believer
I think there probably are aliens I
think you're you're smiling when you're
saying is well the catch so we were
talking about this before the show so I
think it's C I think it was like the
Drake Equation or whatever it is like no
number of planets great complacent Fermi
paradox yes yes so you go through the
probability it's like is there probably
life somewhere else in the universe just
based on pure numbers like probably then
the next question that you have is do
aliens have fats you know what somebody
comes in and brings up that question
they've been listen for a long time yeah
so that one really got me thinking I
think that's the harder question so I
was thinking you know how many species
are there on earth and so I looked it up
there's over eight million eight million
species on earth apparently yeah I think
that's a lot yeah I'm guessing that goes
all the way down you know single-cell
orgasm
I'd have species and how many of these
species have had
that's did you google that too I did not
I just I just assumed it was us Joe how
many species on earth have plants all
right so you see so if you follow that
there's 8 million species on earth were
the only ones that have pets then that
that's pretty damn rare so my guess
would be there's aliens but they don't
have pets man I think they got pets
I think they got pets yeah just cuz
aliens is so broad right like I don't
know way brightens up the question we
talked beforehand a buddy of mine who
will go unnamed because he would be
absolutely mortified if I said that he
said this said to me but your pets have
pets and I was like what do you mean and
he said well your dog has a what we call
a toy humans or I dumb us we call them
toys but your dog plays with an
inanimate object that maybe your dog
thinks that's its pet and I was like Dan
that's a really good way to look at it I
don't know if you're right but like
really expanding my mind right now
blows your mind and well cuz then it
gets into like you know Toy Story right
like has if you leave the room the toys
I'll talk to each other I think actually
in Toy Story one of the toys had a pet I
think so yeah I think so yeah all right
Jay you got an answer for us on the
species how many species have pets
there's no answer all right the
unanswered questions of life what one
question do you have for me to end this
thing yeah so you talked with a ton of
really smart people investors what
differentiates the top two or three
investors that you've talked to from you
know the top 10% so I'm gonna cheat
because I actually asked this question
to mark usko who what I what market I
first decided to work together medium
and Jason were sitting there and I said
something to him like you know explain
what you've done in your career right
essentially what was one of the
questions out of many that we talked
about and what I found fascinating about
Mark was he was always in the allocator
seat for a long time right at Notre Dame
UNC and even a horn Creek and so he has
met with
thousands of managers including the very
very top right so one of you know in
Marc's words one of his mentor's and and
friends is a Julia Roberts and a tiger
right and you kind of go through that
whole kind of era of investors the
absolute best in the world
he knows he's allocated to all the way
down to probably some that and they're
not being very good right and so when I
asked him the question I said what
separates the five best from the one
percent right which essentially the same
question you're asking right like the
absolute best in the world from the ones
who are really really really good and
without flinching anything he took a
breath he said to me immediately like Oh
duh he goes they cut their losers faster
than anyone and they press they're
winners harder than anyone else and so
cutting losers I think is a pretty well
understood concept right hey I've got
some kind of risk profile or stop-loss
or whatever and if I down at X percent I
cut and live to fight another day but
the concept of pressing the winners was
one that I really pushed explain that
more and what he essentially said is
Soros Cohen Dalia all these guys have
this knack for what Mark calls doubling
up so in times of absolute despair when
everyone's running fear the Bloods in
the street etc they're sitting there
they're cool calm collected and they
double up and so when you think about
investing you don't think about those
guys being kind of Grand Slam hitters
right you think of them more as
consistent returns over twenty thirty
forty years but if you I should go back
and look like Soros broke a bank like
like my favorite story is I'm gonna
forget the guys name who's the guy who
chased the naval ship from like
Argentina or whatever the guy he goes
and he buys the rest are dead
was it Loeb no I would probably do it no
not I know neither I'm gonna forget the
name but there's an investor if you just
google it he basically he goes in he
buys super distressed government debt
and tries to buy it you know first
pennies on the dollar and then at some
point either trust
paid par value or basically strikes a
deal right and says hey look you know I
bought your debt for five cents on the
dollar if you pay me 30 cents on the
dollar I'll go away right sometimes they
do it and sometimes they say you know
basically [ __ ] you and no and so one of
the cases he hired I think it was like a
private army to storm a naval ship that
was off the coast of like Somalia or
something they actually took a ship
right I can't remember they took the
ship or not but like they definitely did
something Oh Paul singer yeah Elliott
capital okay yeah Joe man you are on top
of it
all right so Paul singer it was an
Argentine naval vessel and they had a
subsidiary of Elliott Capital won an
injunction in a Ghana in Ghanian
Superior Court to hold a ship in the
port city and it's like dude you're
really serious man
you went after a naval ship of a country
and had it held in a port until they
paid you the money they owe you
that's it see why it's serious and so
it's like is that pressing the winners
is that cutting the losers iphone the
hope of like that guy's going to really
really extremes that I think a lot of
other investors wouldn't do so that's my
answer it's not really my answer it's
more Marc's answer but when he said it
to me it's just stuck with me that like
cut the losers press the winners and
that knack for doubling up I think kind
of separates people has there been
anybody in crypto other than Morgan
Creek that that has stood out to you as
you know kind of inviting that I'm gonna
answer no and the reason is I know
people who I'm very impressed by I don't
think we've had enough time to see like
to do it in 2017 literally you could
have thrown a rock left-handed and you
know hit some kind of profit did you do
it in 18 just do in 19 or go do it in 20
like we're talking about for most of the
fund managers three to four year you
know history and one of those was such
an outlier compared to traditional
markets that's unfair to say like oh
you're you know you're a genius you're
great at this because that one
scenario so I think you probably need to
market cycles right you need two bowls
to Bears get through both of them if
you're sitting there like you know the
what is uh Jim Simon's right for said
hey we've done 66% a year
okay you don't have for twenty thirty
years like you're probably pretty good I
think that we just need more time to
identify who and who in crypto could do
that
and the big question going back to your
thing about the macro is that gonna be
you know people like jump people like
Renaissance etc that are well
established players in other markets who
come into crypto or will we see kind of
the digitally native investor or firm
kind of rise up and end up being that uh
that group I don't know we'll see all
right we're uh we're ending this frankly
because plane is calling me and and he's
gonna yell at me if I don't hurry up and
go meet her so shout out Polina thanks
for interrupting the podcast if you
listen to this far now you know you're
embarrassed
oh alright listen Peter I really
appreciate you coming in this is super
fun we're gonna have to do this more
often but uh where can people find info
at jump Capcom info at jump Capcom
Twitter is probably best just at the
Chicago glut Chicago VC yeah alright man
thank you so much thank you pop sound of
fun